there is a creepy creepy dude who is in
a viral tick tock video who is begging
to speak to your children
i want to talk to the kids parents watch
the video and then hand the phone over
to the young kids hi there um i get
asked a lot are you a boy or a girl and
i love that question
and so i wanted to just
tell you
sometimes human beings are more than boy
or girl
sometimes we're something else sometimes
we're both
sometimes um we kind of float
in between and sometimes we're a boy
sometimes we're a girl
um because human beings are creatures
and we're wild and exciting
we are wild aren't we and sometimes
we're a little more wild than at other
times and we talked about this yesterday
there was a guy who there was a headline
in the new york post
my husband is gay and we have two kids
and we have a wonderful intimate life
together and
everyone's making fun of this article
and i pointed out what's what's wrong
with it
why is every sexual choice
and sexual identity and sexual desire
choice valid
except for that guys that guy is saying
look i'm a gay guy i have this natural
sexual inclination but i want to have a
family i want to practice my religion i
want to be a part of my culture and my
tradition
and so i'm just going to repress that
part of me and i'm going to cultivate
these other parts of me and i'm not
gonna be deceitful about it i'm just
gonna i'm just gonna do that it seems
like he has a great life and they have a
nice time together and the woman
acknowledges she says physical
attraction is not obviously it's not the
bedrock of our relationship but there is
something actually deeper than that and
i'm kind of okay with that i actually
like that physical attraction is not the
basis of our relationship because looks
are going to fade but there's something
deeper there
when i watch that creepy guy on the tic
toc video trying to talk to your kids
about how sex isn't real and you know
boys should wear lipstick and be fluid
and whatever
it reminds me
repression is a good thing
repression is a really good thing it
gets a real bad rap these days but
repression is good we all have
inclinations and things that are a
little weird about us that we ought to
repress every single one of us does
and some of us i guess a little more
than others if you're a guy who thinks
that he's a woman and wants to dress up
in all that glitter paint and talk to a
bunch of kids then you've got a lot of
things that you ought to repress but you
should repress them the reason that it
gets a bad rap is because we're still in
the thrall of sigmund freud we're still
in the thrall of of the era of
psychology that that thought the human
brain resembled a steam engine
the thought that the way our desires and
our mind works is that we have these
natural desires there's no way to change
them ever and so if we don't let them
out if we don't blow off a little steam
we're going to go crazy and explode but
that's not actually how the mind and
desire work
okay different eras it's interesting
different eras
seem to map the their vision of what how
the mind works on the prevailing
technology at the time
so these days we're beginning to think
of the mind as a computer because what's
the big technology of our time is the
computer before that it was the steam
engine before that it was the printing
press this idea of making impressions
imprinting on your mind
but
actually the real way the mind and
desire work are sort of the opposite of
the steam engine freud view
the real way it works is
that virtue and vice are habits so
you'll know you'll know this if if
you've ever dealt with an addiction
the more you give in to your addiction
the less control you have over it if
you're a drinker the more you drink the
harder it is not to take that drink
so it's true of sex it's true of
gluttony it's true of all of these
things
and the more you repress those things if
you're a recovering alcoholic
the further away you get from those
first hundred days 200 days two years
five years the easier it becomes because
virtue and vice are habits so i'm not
saying that that guy is obviously a very
confused guy and he's got a lot of
problems if he wants to be talking to
kids about how he's really a girl but
but
it does actually get a little bit easier
it's uh it's not good for him to be
indulging this craziness it's not good
for him it's not good for society it's
not good for the kids he's trying to
talk to it's not good for anybody
it's not good for our society's grasp on
reality
and so
if we encourage that behavior we're
going to get more of it it's going to be
harder not to do that if we discourage
that and we encourage that that
naughty little word the r word
repression
actually i think we'll all probably get
along a little better i know it's a very
unpopular view these days but it is
obviously
correct ring it get that notification i
appreciate it sometimes you won't get
notifications even when you ring the
bell so head on over to apple podcast
spotify stitcher google play wherever
you get your audio podcasts subscribe to
the michael knowles show leave a five
star review if you wouldn't mind
see you next time
[Music]
[Music]